it's great to welcome to the program
today stephen donziger who's a human
rights attorney who helped indigenous
groups in ecuador win a historic 10
billion dollar pollution judgment
against chevron if you want to help what
he's doing you can go to freedziger.com
it's really great having you on i
appreciate your time
well thanks for having me david i
appreciate it so to start with
what first brought your attention to the
effects of oil drilling
uh in ecuador and and and how did you
first get involved in all of this
yeah that's a great question i mean i
was a year out of law school back in the
early 90s uh i was
one of my classmates was from ecuador
and he told me about this and i was part
of a team in the early 90s that went
down to investigate what turned out to
be you know the worst oil disaster on
the planet or so we thought we called it
the amazon chernobyl
essentially what we discovered is that
texaco an american company now chevron
had deliberately dumped billions of
gallons of cancer-causing oil waste onto
indigenous ancestral lands in the amazon
creating a wave of cancers and other
health and economic problems for the
people
we filed a lawsuit
as a result of that first trip and 28
years later here i am still our team is
still fighting to hold chevron
accountable we won the lawsuit by the
way they just have not paid yet
and that's where the battle is at this
point
there are so many different aspects of
this to talk about including the
eventual charges against you as you talk
about the fact that the judgment has has
not been paid just to pick something and
and we'll kind of go through these
different things as
this was going on and you were working
on this the documentary film crude was
being produced
and one might argue that the production
of the film
opened the door
to allege fraud against you by what was
allegedly left out of the film so can
you talk to us a little bit about your
involvement in the film and whether in
hindsight it was a mistake
sure um so in 2007 joe burlinger who's
an acclaimed documentary filmmaker
decided to make a film about you know
really this epic battle by indigenous
groups against chevron
and their legal team of which i was a
part
um i thought the film was great it came
out in 2009 it's called crude you can
still get it on netflix or on youtube
but more to the point is chevron when
they started to lose the case in ecuador
based on the evidence tried to exploit
the film to come after me
um let me be very very clear chevron has
alleged that i committed some sort of
fraud down in ecuador i reject that it's
never been proven i've never been
charged with a crime and the reality is
28 different appellate judges six
appellate courts in ecuador and canada
have rejected that that theory
but they tried to claim that based on
the movie and some certain things i said
in the movie which frankly were in
politic you know just
stuff i was saying with the camera on
you know 15 years ago was somehow
evidence of fraud and it's never been
accepted by any court
and i reject it and again you know the
judgment in ecuador that i help win
um has been affirmed by multiple
appellate courts around the world so
it's a valid judgment and you know i
just reject that but it's a good film
people want to see it because it really
does capture a lot of what was going on
in ecuador at the time it's so to and to
answer the one piece of that that i that
i didn't hear an answer to in hindsight
did it create problems for that film to
be well that's that's a question you
know it's funny that's a very that's an
important question and i get asked that
a fair amount like if you could do it
over would you have made the film yeah
um i don't know you know when you go
through a journey like i've been on you
sort of operate on the information you
have at the time you make decisions and
the information i had at the time and my
clients more importantly the people of
ecuador i was working with thought it
would be really good for their campaign
to illuminate via a film
you know the injustices that were being
inflicted upon them by chevron
um you know i nor did they anticipate
that how chevron would try to exploit it
for litigation purposes had we known
that maybe my clients would have made a
different decision but you know at this
point it's water under the bridge the
fact is the film is out there yeah it's
a good film and i think overall my
personal assessment is that it helps the
campaign
so okay i want to be precise in how i
kind of broach this this next topic as
you pointed out
there have been
allegations made that the judgment you
obtained
was obtained
through
uh
racketeering extortion wire fraud
witness tampering money laundering etc
you've denied those allegations and you
correctly point out
those have not been proven in court it's
beyond my ability here to examine every
single one of those individually i've
done a fair share of research about this
i can't unequivocally say there's no
merit to any of it but you're completely
right that none of it's been proven in
court
ultimately your imprisonment in the
united states and the suspension of your
law license was not based on any of that
but contempt is that correct that's
contempt of court yes and that is a
misdemeanor
it was treated that way in my case i
mean if i may i think there's a bigger
issue here that i'd like to point out
fairly limited time we have yeah you
know because there's obviously no way in
this limited time we go through all
these allegations right
you know the big issue is it's been
proven in a court of law and chevron has
admitted that its predecessor company
texaco deliberately dumped literally
billions of gallons of toxic waste in
the amazon which is
literally killing thousands of people as
we speak yes
in my view as their defense strategy
they're like oh let's distract from that
by focusing on steve donziger okay so
the more we talk about me and i sort of
you know when i agree to be on the show
like i obviously knew this but like the
more we talk about me the less we talk
about the real problem
which is the poisoning of the amazon in
a way that is decimating indigenous
groups even hurtling them toward
extinction that's the real issue here so
the issue's not me it's them now if we
want to talk about me and their
allegations against me i'm happy to do
that and i do that all the time because
again
they've never been proven in a court of
law and i you know puts me on the
defensive which i don't like yeah and to
be clear about them but yeah but they're
simply i'm just telling you
they're simply unproven and in my view
they're not true it's just a strategy
it's like a corporate playbook to
distract attention from a human rights
atrocity that chevron committed by
focusing on the lawyer and you see this
all the time and the bigger issue to me
in a society where and i don't think
this is a right left political issue
it's like what kind of society do we
want to have where you can advocate for
people you know lawyers should be able
to do their jobs and advocate without
being personally attacked by the party
that they beat in court and that's
what's happened to me with the help
unfortunately of a federal judge here
who've accused of being you know biased
and and the final thing i'll point out
the united nations working group on
arbitrary detention which is a very
respected legal body that's been cited
by our own state department on many of
an occasion where they point out people
who've been arbitrarily detained
ruled in september that the united
states government should release me
immediately i'm just not free even
though i'm home i'm i'm in detention at
home right now yes that they should
release me immediately and paying me
compensation because my detention
violates multiple provisions of
international law and is clearly
retaliation against my advocacy for
indigenous groups in a case that has
been i think manipulated by chevron and
the fossil fuel industry i know that's a
lot to absorb
but the larger issue is my case raises
it goes way beyond me and it really
raises a lot of issues about what kind
of freedom we want what what's the role
of lawyers in our society can you do
climate justice work without being
locked up i mean what's happened to me i
think is just wrong and it's not
indicative of the best part of our
country it's very unusual in the united
states to have a lawyer a climate
justice lawyer like me locked up and i
just think it's it's wrong
with no question and to be clear if i
don't mention as a jumping off point for
this conversation that the allegations
exist i'm not doing my job but i can't
completely concede it's beyond the scope
of this to adjudicate them i'm totally
cool with how you're asking the question
and i love your work generally i'm happy
to take the question i just wanted to
make the larger point
when it comes to
the
ulterior motives
what is your assertion about the role of
uh the american
court system
judge kaplan etc and chevron formerly
known as texaco
look i think as a general matter our
federal judiciary in particular has
become very politicized in the last two
three decades
in a way it never was before and i think
i'm sort of paying the price for that
personally right now um you know there's
a whole there's different groups in the
judiciary and i think it's the
appointment of judges has become so
political
that you're getting judges now on the
bench that are really carrying out i
think
political agendas rather than doing what
they should be doing which is looking at
the facts and ruling on the law in the
most neutral way possible so
you know what judge kaplan has done to
engineer my detention without a jury i
want to emphasize that i never had a
jury
he manipulated the case such that you
know that i wouldn't get a jury
i couldn't defend myself you know in
other words the allegation against me on
the contempt side was that i didn't
comply with this court order that i
turned my computer over to chevron and i
the reason i didn't comply is i appealed
it
to protect the privileges held by my
clients in ecuador their privileged
information their identities they would
have been hurt had this information been
released and been put at risk their
lives would have been put at risk
so i thought i behaved ethically and
i'll point out there's never been a
lawyer in the history of our country
who's been charged criminally for doing
what i did that is challenging a civil
discovery order on appeal it's never
happened before so why is it happening
to the one guy who actually won a 10
billion dollar judgment against chevron
i mean it makes no sense and i'll make
this point when judge kaplan charged me
he went to the sdny the federal
prosecutor here in manhattan
to ask them to prosecute the case and
they refused to prosecute me
he then rather than letting it sit he
then appointed a private law firm to
prosecute me seward and kissel
and he didn't disclose and we found out
seven months later that this law firm
seward and kissel had had chevron as a
client it has massive has a numerous
clients at high levels of the fossil
fuel industry so this became in my
opinion the nation's first private
criminal prosecution
they immediately detained me pre-trial
on a misdemeanor which is unheard of i
mean it locked me up in my home with an
ankle bracelet and because it covered
the trial kept getting delayed that
ended up lasting 20 um
four months i'm sorry 26 months two
years and two months
and on top of that the judge who was
also appointed by judge kaplan judge
prescott
sentenced me to six months in prison
where i ended up reporting to federal
prison for
you know defending my clients in the
amazon and i just think it was grossly
unfair i ended up getting out after 45
days but i'm now back home in detention
to serve the rest of my sentence so all
in all for this misdemeanor where the
maximum sentence
is six months
i am going to end up serving close to
three years by the time it's over and so
a couple of other details on that the at
one point there was an 800 000
bail set for a misdemeanor that's the
highest in u.s history for a misdemeanor
if i understand correctly
that's our understanding so on top of
being the first person charged with this
kind of misdemeanor locked up prior to
trial
i was also given the highest bail ever
for a lawyer on a misdemeanor in us
history and i'll point out that that 800
000 bail was actually higher than three
of the four
police officers involved in the killing
of george floyd which i find astounding
i mean
there's people who commit serious
serious violent crimes who have lower
bails than i got
um
when judge prescott uh
wrote the ruling against you
um
there was this
question
as to
what connect specific connection there
was with the ruling
in ecuador and i know you've generally
spoken about
political interests
you know among the ranks of judges etc
is there anything more specific about
judge prescott that you think should be
understood or known about the connection
to fossil fuels
yes i mean and let me just say i i
respect judges in the rule of law like
i'm i'm a lawyer um and i don't mean to
disrespect judge prescott but there's a
couple problems with her presiding over
my case one is she's a leader of the
federalist society which of to which
chevron is probably the largest funder
the federalist society is a legal
organization it's a fine legal
organization but it is very
pro-corporate and a lot of corporations
fund it and she is a very public leader
and she you know identifies with an
organization that gets funds from
chevron
and i just think that's a major conflict
of interest i don't think she should
have presided over my case
and
you know the other thing i'll point out
about judge prescott is i don't think
she ever should have been appointed to
this case because you know there's rules
here in the federal judiciary and in new
york in particular that cases need to be
signed randomly
and judge kaplan i believe chose her for
a reason they're close colleagues
they've been on the bench together for
over 25 years
and i think she treated me very unfairly
i mean she's the one who made the
decision to lock me up pre-trial for
over two years
you know on a theory that i was a risk
of flight like i'm really gonna i have a
wife and a teenage son i'm really gonna
flee it's absurd the country
um you know to avoid a misdemeanor i
mean so so there was all these things
happening where i believe she and judge
kaplan sort of
colluded to impose a very punitive
um
suffering on me punishment before i was
ever convicted
of a crime and i will point out that my
so-called conviction which again i
assert my innocence it's under appeal
okay right now
um
was imposed without a jury i insisted on
a jury
you know so i could have an unbiased
fact finder rather than a person i
believe was a biased judge and judge
prescott repeatedly denied me a jury
repeatedly refused to remove the
prosecutor even though she was from the
chevron law firm the private prosecutor
so there are all these features to the
trial that led the united nations jurors
to conclude there was a what they called
a staggering level of judicial bias in
my case
it's uh it's an incredible and
disturbing story in a number of
different ways we've been speaking with
stephen dunziger and you can learn much
more about what's going on at
freedonziger.com
i really appreciate your time and you
giving us your insights into what took
place
thank you david i appreciate your work
as well thanks for having me